I just wanted to tell you guys something,
because I've been kind of lying to you guys and I've been holding back
something, but I think it's now time to come clean. Um,
so basically,
yo what's happened guys.
So today we are at the airport now and we are going to Montreal because I want
to show you guys my childhood I'll show you where I grew up, but, uh, yeah,
it's gonna be a long flight, probably like six hours, but, um, yeah,
I'll see you there.
[inaudible].
And here we are back in my room, back in Montreal.
Yeah. It's quite a small room.
I just want to give you guys a little tour of my humble beginnings,
but um, yeah, I'm probably going to go sleep soon. It gets pretty late,
but I just want to show you a few things. Let's check it out. Ooh,
look at this picture. This was a high school trip and this is me.
There you go. Yeah.
Then I had a little desk. I mean, obviously I didn't have a laptop here.
I didn't spend much time here, but I labeled my little drawers.
Like this same means drawings in French.
There used to be something else here. But if you just check out the books,
what is this from the bar to the bedroom,
two 11 rules. I come on focus,
the 11 rules for picking up and pressuring women.
This is why I used to read as a kid. Hilarious.
And here you can see diary, which is a,
which is like a Darwin. It had an elementary school. Well,
let me find you the good part.
So here you can see clearly that I liked this girl called Cheryl. Cause I wrote,
you know, I decided to not care about Cheryl stuff. We're just friends. Now.
Anyways, today, Cheryl got mad at me again. Yeah. Tomorrow.
I'm going to share Rose House. Hey, Hey. Hey. Hey man.
I think Cheryl hates me again. I did a big mistake. Holy.
This is quite funny. So I think,
I think I was a graphing how much I like each of my friend.
Let's see. There's Alex Martin gave Alex was at 87%.
That is so funny. You can see how I became a data scientist.
Yo and there's and there's even like a reference chart.
A hundred percent means can share secrets. Almost impossible.
Negative 20 is. I hate it. But is there anyone negative 20? No,
I don't think so. All right.
I hope you enjoy this little glimpse of my cringy life. My cringey.
What was I? 12 year old or 11, 11 or 12 year old self.
Uh, I enjoyed reading that. I'm kind of glad that I wrote that when I was a kid,
but uh, yeah. Anyways, I'm gonna,
I'm going to prepare for tomorrow because tomorrow we're having a Montreal
meetup. Hopefully someone shows up. I don't know. We'll see. Um,
see you tomorrow.
All right, welcome. So this is where I grew up and uh, yeah,
it's kinda sad cause I want it to go to burger King because I want to tell you
guys a story about why we should, you know,
spend a little bit more money when we're younger and there's like a philosophy
behind it. But unfortunately it became a fricking Starbucks.
So this is basically like a Walgreen's I used to go to a lot. Um,
yeah, it's called shoppers in Canada,
but in French it's called Philmont P it's kinda like a Walgreens and a yeah.
I used to go there a lot. Hit on a cashier, but uh,
good times. Ooh.
And this used to be my local gym. It was actually pretty cheap.
I think it was like $30 a month. That's why I used to get jacked. Good times.
Good times.
This is McDonald's my first job ever. I first lived a job.
I mean, I worked with my parents. I started this job when I was 15.
I worked about a year and a half and a man,
like I was the first one in the history of this MacDonald that did not get a
raise after a year.
It was pretty crazy because it's pretty much mandatory for you to get a raise
after a year. But how was the only one that did not get one? Yeah,
I was that bad. Hello.
As you can see, most of my fans are quite awkward
talking guys. Pretend I'm not here. Maybe only one lady. It's not.
So what's guys, Joe was in the bathroom right now.
So like when I interview some people. Yeah.
Like honestly I think drama would actually be kind of cool,
but like he's actually really in real life. Like I thought he'd be hot,
like kind of cool, but like he's actually so lame and everything, man, like
you guys, I don't know, man, this small kid who thinks he knows everything,
I'm just here for the a Touche drama.
Yeah. I thought somebody was going to be there, man.
It was funny.
What were you guys talking about?
It's getting really late.
Jason went on Jolla. I'm Joma
where you guys are bouncing. Really tough.
All right. So you guys,
you can come back. You can come back now.
I'm actually lonely. All right guys.
So that was a pretty dope meetup. Thank you everyone for hanging out with me,
even though they left like 30 minutes after, but it's okay. I don't know.
I think it was cool. So now we're going to do, we're just going to,
we're just going to go grab some food, you know, chill, do some other stuff,
but yeah. See you later.
I father, which
I think about it and she knows it.
I don't want to let it take control guys.
Every time that she gets close, she pulls me.
[inaudible] you'll take me places.
[inaudible]
uh, Hey guys. Um,
I just wanted to tell you guys something because I've been kind of to you guys
and I've been holding back something,
but I think it's not an time to come clean. Um,
so basically I don't even like in water that much. Um,
like I'm not even sponsored by them,
but I just thought it was kind of funny and you guys really liked it.
I should like look for better, but yeah,
I don't want to be like in water. Oh. And also meet Jasmine. She's a,
she's like a she's
she's going to be really big really soon. I think. So, uh,
if you want to listen to awesome covers of popular songs and you know, what,
what kind of songs do you like do pop that all of us secret.
So if you want, you're interested in listening.
Yeah. It's pretty cool. Check out her channel, but yeah.
Hope you like the video and I'm going to see you guys next time.